we're learning new details about a
possible cover-up and a lawsuit just
filed this morning in the Jeffrey
Epstein case a CBS News source has
information showing how jailers may have
tried to hide mistakes surrounding the
apparent suicide of Epstein the US
Attorney General has stepped in to make
changes at the Metropolitan Correctional
Center where the suspected sex
trafficker was found dead on Saturday
molal ng is outside that federal jail in
new york city with what the new lawsuit
says well good morning one of Jeffery
Epstein's alleged victims has filed a
civil lawsuit that targets not only the
multimillionaires estate but his alleged
co-conspirators including British
socialite and Epstein's ex-girlfriend
Elaine Maxwell as well as three other
females referred to in the suit as the
recruiter the secretary and the maid
none of the women had been charged and
Elaine Maxwell vehemently denies the
allegations all of this comes as the
Department of Justice and the Attorney
General William bar have reassigned the
warden here at the Metropolitan
Correctional Center pending the outcome
of investigations by the FBI and
Inspector General in the meantime the
warden of upstate New York
Otis ville will take over the prison
here also the Department of Justice
announced two guards at the Metropolitan
Correctional Center have been placed on
leave and the DOJ may not be done saying
in a statement that additional actions
may be taken as the circumstances
warrant the shake-up comes as a law
enforcement source tells CBS News prison
guards working when Epstein apparently
died by suicide may have falsified
reports to make it look like they were
checking in on Epstein when they were in
fact not we're told the alleged sex
trafficker may have been dead for one to
two hours before his body was found
Saturday morning the sources say the FBI
is looking to review cameras inside the
MCC the Metropolitan Correctional Center
here where Epstein was being held at
least two of the prison guards here have
hired attorneys but it's unclear Tony if
they are the same prison guards who have
been placed on leaf molla thank you very
much